Good morning, John. It's Tuesday, January
23rd. If you're wondering why I'm blowing
on my wine, it's because it's tea. But I needed
something that I could toast with. Congratulations
on your Printz nomination. That wasn't exciting
enough; I need to be more excited about that.
To the Printz Award! To An Abundance of Katherines!
To Katherines! There's one sitting right here.
She's waving. To silver medals! To not quite
doing as good as you did the last time!
Sorry, that was kinda mean.
So I was in a bookstore today, and the lady
came up to me and said, "You're John Green's
brother." Oh-ho! So it turns out I'm famous
now. Well, she might very well be your biggest
fan. She has a section in her bookstore devoted
entirely to you. In fact, there are several
sections in her book store devoted entirely
to you. Well they're all kind of small.
Uh, she had heard that you won the Printz
Prize. I don't know what you're gonna do with
all of them, man. You're just rackin' 'em
up. What do you do with two Printz Awards?
Do you actually get a thing? Do you get, like,
a statue? Ah congratulations! Or do you just,
you know, every single one of your books get
a sticker on it. Which is cool. I like the
sticker, I think the sticker is good. Or do
you just get more money? Do they give you
more money? Is there any, you know, reward?
Now there's something that I wanted to talk
to you about. When you received the information
that you were getting the Printz Award, one
of the things that you did not do was your
Happy Dance. Is your Happy Dance actually
your Happy Dance? Or are you just trying to
entertain us? Because if you're just trying
to entertain us, then this thing isn't real,
man, and it has to be real! Or you know, it
could be fake. We could start faking things,
and that might be interesting. For example,
I generally sit by the fire, with a glass
of wine... in my girlfriend's coat...
Katherine: Girlfriend?
Hank: Girlfriend, huuhhh... eheheh, yes...
girlfriend's coat. We aren't married 'cause
this is fake time. I'm lying about things.
Obviously.
So I was recently at your friend Maureen Johnson's
blog. She discussed a long conversation which
you and Johnson and Lockhart had, concerning
the suffix, "in your pants." It turns out
that every book title becomes better when
you add "in your pants" to the end of the
title. I'm going to go around this lovely
cabin and find books.
The Dance of the Dissident Daughter in Your
Pants! Present Moment, Wonderful Moment in
Your Pants. Stumbling on Happiness in Your
Pants. The Left Hand of Darkness in Your Pants.
The Student Bible in Your Pants?
Yeah... So... I'll see you tomorrow.
And I know that you don't personally know
this, but Katherines in your pants is actually
quite a nice thing. I don't know about an
abundance of Katherines... I promise, I don't.
But one Katherine in my pants... is quite
nice.